hello there I'm John Oliver
host of last week tonight's YouTube
channel um we were off this week in
observance of Independence Day or as
they call it where I'm from the day of
colonial aggression this this past week
I'm guessing I brought Supreme Court
rulings international conflict and 7000
total hours of major-league baseball
games or in layman's terms three major
league baseball games take that
America's pastime um but but the most
important story from the past seven days
was of course fireworks we in America
love fireworks why well because they're
like sparkly guns you can shoot at the
sky and that is why last week tonight
has brought you comprehensive coverage
of every July the 4th fireworks display
that happened this week first of all
parking was a nightmare for you
there were several spots that looks like
spots but turned out not to be spots the
experience brought couples of 20 years
to the precipice of divorce classical
music was playing because everything
seems like a cultural event when there's
classical music there if they play
Vivaldi at monster truck rallies schools
would start taking field trips there the
fireworks themselves proceeded mainly as
follows one red one exploded that's then
then a blue one it also exploded and
then a white one followed and also
exploded then of course red white and
blue all at once
that's fireworks greatest hits right
there there were a bunch that went like
aah
and there was one the wind
and that that last one's my favorite a
Louisville a slow explosion it reminds
me of watching video of John McCain over
time good then there were some more
regular ones at this point the
spectators began checking their watches
and going towards the end a whole
ton of fireworks all went off at the
same time almost as if the guy running
the fireworks said it let's do them
all I've got American Idol DVR'd the
classical music then reached a crescendo
and stopped abruptly allowing all those
in attendance to hear the terrified
yelps of all the children and pets
nearby everyone then applauded like the
fireworks were going to take a bow then
they all stood up walked back to their
terrible parking spots and made the
silent agreement not to think about
fireworks at all until next fourth of
July when they perform this exact ritual
again and that ladies and gentlemen is
what makes America great the ability to
wholeheartedly embrace excitement while
letting disappointment and failure slip
away as quickly as you can that's it
shut down yourself a can of Partridge
you you're safe you go you go he'll be
back next week at 11:00 with a keep
Johnson keep judging we'll be back next
what
with a new episode the electrical until
then short patriotically our home will
see you go hey you